[Música]
la presencia de Nicolás maduro genera
división en la Cumbre de líderes
sudamericanos que se lleva a cabo en
Brasilia mientras Lula da Silva pide que
haya integración chile asegura que la
situación de Derechos Humanos en
Venezuela es una realidad y Uruguay pide
que no se tape el sol con un dedo
en Colombia crece la esperanza de hallar
con vida a los niños que se perdieron en
una selva tras un accidente aéreo hace
un mes el hallazgo de algunas frutas
mordidas y unas pequeñas huellas los
llevan a pensar que los menores están
muy cerca de ser encontrados
la fiscalía de Guatemala pide 40 años de
prisión para el periodista José Rubén
Zamora por los supuestos delitos de
chantaje asociación ilícita y lavado de
dinero Zamora fue detenido hace casi un
año días después de lanzar críticas por
corrupción contra el presidente
Alejandro yamatei
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda a Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil donde representantes de 12 países
de Sudamérica discutieron un nuevo
mecanismo de cooperación regional aunque
con divisiones respecto a algunos temas
Como por ejemplo la presencia del
presidente de Venezuela Nicolás Maduro
debido a las acusaciones de violaciones
a los derechos humanos en su país Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
los líderes de 11 países reunidos en
Brasilia la capital de Brasil con un
objetivo reafianzar la unidad de
Sudamérica una propuesta del presidente
de izquierdas Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
mientras estemos divididos no haremos de
Sudamérica un continente desarrollado
con todo su potencial
la integración debe ser el objetivo
permanente de todos nosotros tenemos que
plantar raíces fuertes para las futuras
generaciones
pero esta no es una tarea sencilla ya
que hay algunas reticencias
especialmente en turno a una figura la
de presidente de Venezuela Nicolás
maduro y es que actualmente hay una
Clara división entre los países
sudamericanos respecto a la reaparición
de maduro en la Esfera internacional
mientras que algunos como Brasil
Argentina o Colombia están a favor de su
reintegración otros como chile o Uruguay
no lo ven con tan buenos ojos
en el sentido en que la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Venezuela era una
construcción narrativa
no es una construcción narrativa es una
realidad es seria sorprendido
cuando se habló de lo que sucede en
Venezuela es una narrativa lo peor que
podemos hacer es tapar el sol con un
dedo
pongámosle el nombre que tiene y
ayudemos pero a pesar de las divisiones
se espera que en este primer encuentro
desde 2014 Las Naciones suramericanas
dialoguen sobre un nuevo mecanismo de
integración regional inspirado en la
antigua unasur ideada por Lula y el
expresidente Hugo Chávez en 2008 pero
que quedó desmantelada con el auge de
los presidentes conservadores en la
región y también en Brasil la cámara
baja del Congreso aprobó el proyecto que
limita la demarcación de las tierras de
los indígenas en el país esta iniciativa
que tiene que pasar todavía por el
senado y por una eventual sanción
presidencial restringiría la demarcación
de nuevas reservas indígenas solo a
tierras que estaban ocupadas por
comunidades nativas cuando Brasil aprobó
su constitución en 1988 la aprobación se
da luego de choques entre policías y
manifestantes indígenas a las afueras de
Sao Paulo los pueblos originarios
señalan que este proyecto limitaría su
capacidad para para obtener el estatus
de protección de sus tierras ancestrales
estamos en una protesta nacional con los
pueblos originarios de este territorio
hoy en nombre de Brasil estamos luchando
por la vida aquí está mi pueblo mi
pueblo guaraní luchando diciendo no a la
ley de la muerte diciendo no a la ley de
la destrucción diciendo no al marco de
tiempo
vamos a Colombia los nuevos hallazgos en
la búsqueda de los niños que
desaparecieron en la selva del guaviare
tras un accidente aéreo dan esperanzas a
las autoridades un mes después de que
fueron vistos por última vez aseguran
que los menores Siguen con vida Nuestro
periodista Luis Muñoz con los detalles
en las últimas horas las fuerzas armadas
han iniciado la que consideran podría
ser la prueba final en la búsqueda de
los niños han llevado hasta la espesa
selva reflectores sonido y perifoneo
terrestre estos tienen potencia para
notarse a entre 500 metros y un
kilómetro y esperan que sea una forma de
atraer a los niños el lunes el general
al mando de la operación informó que
creían haber estado a 100 metros de los
niños tras encontrar una huella fresca
de la mayor de las niñas de 13 años en
las semanas anteriores habían encontrado
un pañal unas tijeras e incluso frutas
mordidas el grupo de búsqueda formado
por militares e indígenas ha recorrido
más de 1.250 kilómetros que es como ir
de Bogotá hasta quito en Ecuador y
retornar hasta la frontera entre
Colombia y Ecuador el perímetro ahora se
reduce a una área de 30 km2 desde la
comandancia de la misión descartan que
pudieran estar en manos de un grupo
armado ilegal basado en las selvas de
Colombia uno de los temores entre la
población en la semana pasada estuvimos
en la base de operaciones en la frontera
con la selva con militares e indígenas
el caso ha traído mucha atención en
Colombia e internacionalmente sobre todo
después de que el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro tuitease que habían sido
encontrados dos semanas después del
accidente información que tuvo que
desmentir al día siguiente el lema desde
entonces para el gobierno desplazado en
terreno los militares y los indígenas ha
sido buscarlos hasta encontrarlos de
hecho esta Unión de militares e
indígenas ha llamado la atención puesto
que la relación históricamente ha sido
de desconfianza y ahora se está poniendo
en valor los conocimientos de la selva
de indígenas de comunidades muy alejadas
así como sus creencias culturales en la
búsqueda
en Guatemala la fiscalía pide 40 años de
cárcel para el periodista José Rubén
Zamora acusado de chantaje asociación
ilícita y lavado de dinero el periodista
que está en prisión preventiva desde
julio pasado la su acusaciones de
corrupción contra el presidente
Alejandro yamatei desde antigua nuestro
corresponsal Andrés Suárez tiene los
detalles de la historia
el destacado periodista guatemalteco
José Rubén Zamora quien ha publicado más
de un centenar de artículos en los que
relaciona al actual presidente Alejandro
yamatei en presuntos casos de corrupción
podría enfrentar hasta 40 años de
prisión esto a razón de la solicitud que
hizo el Ministerio Público o la fiscalía
hoy en la audiencia de la fase final del
juicio en su contra en el tribunal
octavo de ciudad de Guatemala los 40
años de prisión estarían repartidos en
20 años y una multa de 38 mil dólares
por presunto lavado de dinero 12 años
por tráfico de influencias presunto
tráfico de influencias y ocho años por
supuesto chantaje y durante la solicitud
de estas penas por parte del Ministerio
Público a José Rubén Zamora se le vio
riendo de manera que a las a la salida
del tribunal explicó entre líneas lo
absurdo de su caso hizo referencia a la
famosa narcotraficante guatemalteca
Marjorie Chacón conocida como La reina
del sur quien pagó 5 años de quien dijo
que mantiene su patrimonio intacto por
haber lavado la suma cercana a los 5 mil
millones de dólares mientras que en su
caso en el que se le acusa de haber
lavado 38 mil dólares Pues podría llegar
a pagar esta dura pena de 40 años no
cesan los las denuncias de organismos
locales e internacionales de que este es
un juicio plagado de todo tipo de
irregularidades donde ha tenido que
prescindir de nueve abogados y donde se
evidencia que el aparato judicial en
Guatemala va en contra de la libertad de
expresión Y responde a la solicitudes
del ejecutivo a sus 66 años Zamora ha
perdido 35 libras Durante los 10 meses
de prisión en que ha estado desde su
captura en julio pasado y está la espera
de la sentencia definitoria aunque se
ampara en poder llevar su caso a los
tribunales internacionales vamos a
Estados Unidos porque el acuerdo sobre
el techo de la deuda superó su primer
obstáculo en el congreso de este país el
comité de reglas de la cámara de
representantes controlado Por los
republicanos aprobó que la iniciativa
negociada entre el presidente Joe biden
y el líder de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy pase al
pleno de la cámara baja el debate en
esta instancia del Congreso Podría
empezar este miércoles para lograr
llevarla al senado y que sea aprobada
antes del 5 de junio
Elizabeth Holmes la responsable del
fraude de teranos ingresó a una prisión
en Texas hace ocho años la mujer creó
una startup tecnológica que prometió
revolucionar los análisis de sangre y
atrajo inversiones por 9 mil millones de
dólares pero todo era un fraude la
empresa nunca desarrolló la tecnología
según reveló un periodista del diario
Wall Street journal hasta el martes
estaba en Libertad bajo fianza y en 2018
el departamento de justicia de Estados
Unidos acusó a Holmes y a su pareja de
varios delitos empresariales
hasta aquí este Informativo en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos los invitamos a
que continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]